the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok I hope you all had a good spring
break and refreshed
I spent three days in DC Bryn storm you
know it's pretty good
so if you recall in the week before our
last lecture we were discussing the wave
propagation in layered structures and we
spend time in deriving the reflectance
with a reflection coefficient you can
have one layer and there are three
strategies one physically what happens
if I have wave comes in the first time
they win me the interface there's
reflection there's transmission go to
the next interface reflashing
transmission so there are infinite
number of reflection and transmission
and of course if their absorption during
the propagation of the wave in the
layers you will the intensity will be
lost
otherwise it's say we wrote down the
strategy is you can always do the plane
wave propagation and if you can write
the plan wave form you can sum up and do
infinite series so we didn't do that in
class but that's what they failed excess
and what we spent time is this so-called
the resultant wave method we say okay
let's group this for propagating which
has the same phase factor or into one
term except now we don't have fixed
relation between incoming and I'll see
in the for propagating because you can
say from the physics there it's multiple
addition right
so we want to find the coefficients and
similarly backward propagating and we
use the continuity of the Maxwell
equation at the boundary and we derive
the expression for the reflection
coefficient so that's what we spend time
on and the third method which is a much
more general so the transfer matrix
method and here you can say we're still
distinguishing forward backward
propagating and we're doing electrical
field and transfer matrix method is
writing down both incident reflected all
group into what's the electric field
component what's the magnetic field
component and because at the interface
these are continuous so it's easy for me
to propagate this through many layers as
long as I have the transfer matrix right
that transfer matrix is the phase factor
it's reading you have general formula
for each layer and we have many layers
it's just a multiplication of those
layers so that's actually most
convenient to use and people used to see
very often and in fact Cynthia
deposition is so common anybody of you
can pick up those method and do design
of multi-layer films to get desirable
properties and so that's in fact I tell
you that I'll ever really seriously took
you know M wave cost that's always where
I started I read the book and you have
to have that patient to write down all
the terms and do your master and get the
appreciation for what's happening it's
the exercise and if you take a square of
this reflection coefficient and here I'm
assuming that it's real em one two and
three is real because you say clearly if
it's a complex number our one two is a
friend nail koi fish
for each interface you can calculate so
even if it's complex number you can use
all the complex lumber operation to the
square but here because I'm taking real
so I can actually write it just in terms
of the regular square rather than
complex conjugate and you can say now
what's interesting what we want to get
in is the phenomena and in my expression
for the reflectance I have a cosine to
Phi term in both the numerator and the
denominator so you know then this
reflectance words will be a pure article
very function because of this cosine
term so let's use this for discussion
and you can of course use a single layer
and you take a dr d phi write this Phi
tool you can say is really D cosine
theta it's more like a thickness in fact
your thickness for the duration
propagation and the / nom de 0 right so
normalized to lambda 0 and this 2 Phi 2
is because of the round-trip right if
you look at the phases we have the
reflection is coming with flat back
so is it forward backward that's a
factor of 2 in phase right so if I take
this into 0 and you can find out where
the maximum minimum is and it happens
when sine 2 Phi 2 equals 0 and for this
we have different solutions whether it's
maximum or minimum so the this of course
it happens when if I substitute the Phi
2 is a 4 pi because that's a factor of 2
and 2 D 2 cosine theta 2 lambda 0
the vacuum eCourse see multiple amber of
pie that's when sign goes to zero M is
an integer right but whether it's a
maximum or minimum
so when M is either lumber so M equals
2l plus 1 let's say our lumber and in
this case at least when theta equals
zero you will find that reflect
reflected this is M one and three mass n
2 square and M 1 and 3 plus n 2 square
square so that's an interesting
expression right it means if I have
those condition map a lot more incidents
here either
also outer angle where you can write the
maximum minimum I'm here writing this
because this expression is simple you
can see that if I choose if I have high
two anti-reflection coding right I have
a surface and I do other reflecting any
reflection and in this case I have a
layer in between and two and you can say
when n 2 is the square root of M 1 and 3
you got a zero flashing right so by
using the interference phenomena this is
a the QR code variation of reflectance
is the interference phenomena
interference of light you can have
maximum or flashing a minimum minimum of
reflection right and when N equals to L
in this case what happens is again I see
that equals zero us a your reflectance
is my mass and three and one plus n 3
square
what does it tell you it tells you you
and though you put a layer there it
doesn't matter it's just like an
interface between 1 & 3 right so you use
this effector to do different optical
coatings and here of course we're only
talking about one layer and you can code
the many layers to have desirable
properties and people do that
for many applications I'll mention more
as we go on so this is just a simple see
example one important Carissa will learn
from this is when we consider wave and
here is a fight tool right if you look
at reflectance and what you have is say
a pure article variation of reflected
that's the in the ferns phenomena right
if you go to clean room right you
deposit layer of film very often some of
you may go in the clean room deposit
layer film and experience the person
will look at the color
after date because of the light white
light comes in is a broadband white
light and because the in the furnace the
fact that some colors reflect more some
color reflect less and if you do a lot
of this you get the experience you can
tell from the color what's the thickness
range you have right and of course the
same film if you look at different angle
you say different color and then again
that's because if you look how Phi 2 is
anger dependent right the face of the
light is say when it depends on the
trajectory it propagates in the material
so this is a one layer film and then we
would go multi-layer
right it's hard to predict when you add
many many layers the inference
phenomenon becomes very complicated and
but say one special multi-layer is this
court yes which corresponds to minimum
and which ones in Maxima which value of
M so here you can say when this we have
here it is the this one is the minimum
right and this one I think it is the
maximum okay so when I have multi-layer
of the film one special case is the
quarter wavelength so when the period of
layers is say you see the path length
equals quarter wavelengths so what I
have one have multi-layer you can choose
a layer one
they are two and you're repeating layer
1 layer 2 right and in this case when I
have 4 PI and one d1 cosine theta 1 over
lambda 0 plus 4 PI into D 2 cos I say
the tool over lambda 0 and this is the
effective layer 1 and layer 2 right when
the effectively equals to L PI I have in
this case the reflectance actually reach
maximum so what happens is if you look
at your as a function of or you can
combine this two as your in fact your
face right let's say in fact your face
or you say you can change either
wavelengths of light if you make your
structure already for different
wavelengths and the woody or say
reflectance have the almost prayer
factor reflection region okay and this
is a 1 this is 0 and when it's a perfect
reflecting that means that they like I'm
saying 100% reflected right and what it
means light is loud loud not an out in
this few layer I decided of incidence
right and so in optics this is called a
stop band and in solid States for
electrons and photons we call the bank
gap if you recall when we discuss the
three dimensional crystals right this
American Durbin gap that's when the wave
functions of electrons are not allowed
in this range of energy so you can say I
mentioned before for optics people the
research direction is going from 1 D 2 3
D this object coatings people have
developed over a hundred years you
rather yellowish people as in only 86
and he said ok let's to 3d biology to
crystals so that this star pad happens
in all directions so that you can pull
real bang gap when you have such a
crystal no matter which direction of
light you shine onto it it's all
reflected right so that's why I joked
before I had the colleague before would
say this is enough photonic prisoner is
a Bragg refactor because this quarter
wavelength stack
called a Bragg reflector and this is the
Bragg condition we talked before x-ray
Brad condition when you have pure air
structure the wave cancels right so this
is the croissant in bra condition and
this is a Bragg reflector so it turns
out if you have with such a periodic
structure no matter how small is
refractive in that contrast when I said
no matter as long as that you have
refractive index contrast right it can
be just no contrast at all right you can
build many layers and have such a
phenomenon so low Marie
when sometimes when people make say we
want high reflection and they don't have
the material that'll give Y interface Y
interface reflectance is here right
you're limited by the refractive index
contrast so what you do is you use
multi-layer Braque reflectors and make
multi-layer structure and there are many
many examples people using those kind of
effects one is semiconductor laser so
some of the semiconductor lasers
actually made out for gallium arsenide
aluminum arsenide right so one of this
normally a semiconductor has a two
configuration why is the a.g meeting so
this is a quantum well we mentioned this
configuration before quantum they are
typically very thin right Henry and
strong so the light will go much wider
region so you use a total internal
reflection
you put a aluminum gallium arsenide in
the surrounding which has a lower
refractive index and in that case the
lighter is a in this region and they
propagate they come out
from the edge of the crystal and the
lighter needs to be amplified so it
needs to go certain distance because the
laser is amplified light emission right
so the amplification is a positive
absorption coefficient we have before
absorption coefficient the light is
decaying exponentially and if you
amplify is growing exponentially but you
need a certain distance grow so in this
edge emitting laser the distance for the
light will oscillate is typically a few
hundred micron and so it has the because
they what they do is after they grow the
similar device they will cleave it
neither lateral interface between air
and the semiconductor so the light comes
to the end they will be refracted and
that's the reflective right if a
reflectance
if the refractive index of maturity per
three to four car last night right you
can go to say that reflectance is about
what if it is three that's 1/4 a square
it's not be right so are they so they
need a long distance to amplified but
people don't like this configuration
because you have to cleave it a light
come from the edge and people spend a
lot of time trying to grew this so that
light can come perpendicular to the
surface in that case this is the quantum
well region and they have to make this
certain thickness half wavelength or
full wavelength okay so that's a cavity
here but the light only travel very
short distance right so in this case you
need a multiple punch you need a high
reflectivity so that the light that is a
bounce back and forth get amplified and
to get a high reflectivity they were
deposit this Bragg reflector on the top
and bottom made of gallium arsenide a
luminous light so in that case after say
the reflective reflectance I the surf
can get over 99% and the light comes
some of the light coming out
perpendicular to the substrate so this
is a weak so vertical cavity surface
emitting laser right so in fact this is
the one that got me interested in this
multi-layer structure and when I first
do research I was aware the heat cannot
get out because in fact those weeks over
you Mindy and what what kind of saved in
97 years it was only at your 1990s they
start to be able to sell it because the
heating issue there and when first when
night goes through those multi-layer
structure they have to put a charge
going through that structure and this
wood becomes a very electrically
resistive and it turns out that also I
started realized that the heater also
has trouble to go through those
multi-layer structures so that's I I
worked on it and when I was doing my PhD
so that's the proc reflector right and
if you use a for example in your lab
sometimes you buy a interference filter
and interference filter is typically
also made of broch reflectors and
sometimes the laser laser wavelengths
like a you want to distinguish different
wavelengths they all made our Bragg
reflector another example interesting
example of this multi-layer not
necessarily purity structure is a
selective surface right and when I say
selective surface I mean wavelength
selective surface and one example is in
the solar thermal collectors you want
the surface absorb thermal radiation but
you do not want the surface radiates
heat all right so the
so ideally what do you want because the
solar radiation is limited to about 2.4
micron so wavelengths of solar radiation
is typically less than 2 point 4 micron
and you want this ideally absorb
emissivity equals 1 for this wavelength
but you may see with equals 0 beyond
that when you heat up an object you
think of a wins law right lambda T about
3000 so for if your object is a 500
Kelvin your witness is a 10 micron
that's the peak wavelength so the
employee emission from the surface is
here so if you can minimize your
emissive ities to 0 you don't lose this
much heat right so that's what the
Selective surface ideally I want the
emissivity 1 and 0 here and how you make
it right you look like I say typically
what is the surface that's a good
reflector that means the refracted it's
the immittance is going to be low
typically metal is a good reflector
right and if you take a copper you take
aluminum they're shiny if they're shiny
that's the again you can calculate now
using the friend nail formula you get a
refractive index or up your constants
you can calculate but the immittance of
metal is typically low the problem is
absorptance is also low right so what
people do is they typically take this
metal and they were cold a few layers
and this you have to optimize computer
code that you optimize different than
the refractive index and the why of this
way Dakota is aluminum they started with
alumina substrate and they called the
changed a I think it's in light regime
environment or oxygen environment right
they change the oxygen pressure so now
it's together you get an aluminum oxide
and
mixture and if you change that come
pressure pressure you'll each layer you
can actually have different mixture and
that way they can do the really cheap
and and the performance is pretty good
they they can gather emissivity
typically around the lining 5% in this
opticore the the solar wrench and
immittance in the infrared range as low
as 5% with three or four layer coating I
went to those companies that do this
kind of coating and their vacuum chamber
is at the football field and they're
doing this because in China the this is
a really low wider use solar summer in
many many household over 100 million
square meters deployed right they do the
really cheap and so you have to look at
those coatings and of course you when
you think of energy I have to look at
their cost but what I want to tell you
is now you can do it using that transfer
matrix it's a computer optimization it's
the more material you choose that's
realistic right and if you design that
you there are a lot about coding
companies outside that will be happy to
do it for you if you have the money okay
and Lex the so so this is a we have
really the optical signal layer a
multi-layer calculation we can do it now
and to continue the discussion what I
want is to look at the case when the
angle of incidence by the first layer is
larger than the critical angle of
incidence right so in this case at a
single interface we know there's total
internal reflection right but all the
formula
we learned for example here this formula
is still valid the only thing I assume
here is real but say you if it's a
complex you can use complex number and
this and you're larger than angle of
incidence you can still use that formula
the math part is identical so what's
interesting is when the angle of
incidence is larger than critical angle
what I have is a cosine see that tool
you can say cuz I see that who is 1
minus sine see that 2 square right
sciency that will you using Snell's law
is a 1-month okay let's see sign see
that 2 square and see that who signs it
at which the law is a sign see that who
n 2 equals N 1 sine theta 1 right so you
can see in this case I have sine theta 2
is larger than 1 above the critical
angle so when I do my cosine theta 1
minus I see that 2 square I get an
imagine umber and that's what we
discussed before we have even less than
wave on the other side so if I have one
single interface this you've a lasting
way of decay exponentially and doesn't
carry energy to the other side but so if
I do this what I write is on one side
see that 1 & 2 square minus 1 I put a
say this now becomes a real number and
you can say my cosine say that who is an
imagined number if I substitute it into
this remember into here now you will say
my reflectance is longer or not longer
one you could be long so it could be
less than 1
right and similarly your transmittance
is a lot longer zero so this is what
happens the optical tunneling so this is
the tunneling in Amla so what happens
physically is I have a high index mid
material in one right and you shoot the
light above the critical angle and the
low Murray
it's totally reflected but on this side
that there is exponentially decay evil
assembly and now if here if you say I B
cosine theta is I times B you can say of
course that depends on B times D - right
otherwise that's exponential decay
it's a exponential function and if this
is a really small that reflectance to
the one right
if this exponential term really small or
this dropout that's still what and when
they say this one Phi 2 D 2 times that B
divided by lambda is not decimal let's
say it's very small actually wherever
it's very large it dropped to zero but
when it's very small I can actually now
have the reflectance that's less than
then they say it's longer one so that's
the colony so what happens is this evil
action wave when I bring a less surface
close by so this is the end to this end
to could be vacuum for example I put a
glass at the vacuum I put a lot of layer
glass right and this why bring the close
this wave started propagating again it's
allowable because of their anger schnell
law in the third medium
the angle if I use the schneller is n 1
sine theta 1 and 2 sine C that you
already see is about critical angle by
the N 3 sine theta 3 and in this media
could be propagating right so this is in
this case what I'll do what they'll have
is the R 2 not equal to 1 and
transmittance is not equal to 0 so I
have final transmission of a tunneling
of this evil a sin wave so tunneling off
and if you look at the distance for that
to happen is when the separation or the
thickness of the film is a comparable to
wave lengths that's an exponential
function right so that gives you the
order of magnitude so this colony
phenomena is valid for all waves right
all those in the first phenomena colony
phenomena brach reflectors Bragg
reflector in the case of electron is the
super lattice you read Ritu's paper
that's a super lattice for going from 3d
to 1d right so all this are applicable
for as long as you treat them as waves
just whether it is a scalar wave for
electron and transverse wave for bacter
wave 4 a.m. and acoustic wave is a more
complicated longitudinal and transverse
so if this is Holly nebula you've
elastin wave for photon there's
corresponding you can do all the
analysis as we did for electron so
electron what we have before is either
one single interface when wave comes in
you have reflection you have
transmission
right and if the energy is less than the
height barrier height you have total
internal total reflection but you have a
uvula in the wave function on this side
and so again if I put a very thin film
right and so this is my structure
sandwich structure layer 1 layer 2 layer
3 right
so electron wave launched the from layer
1 and if the energy is less than the
barrier height u 0 if this is the energy
of electron so in this case I have a
relaxing wave that can so bad if my
layer 2 is thin enough you can come out
and become propagating into the third
medium so that's the termini of electron
and you could use again the same
analysis similar analysis we do for the
Optio wave and this is scalar wave it is
easier you'll get the transmittance for
electron in this case is a 4 e energy u
0 masse and for e u 0 mass E Plus u 0
square cinch function Square D and 2m u
0 Master Yi and H bar square so this is
the transmittance and typically this
cinch function is the exponential
function so it grows large
so the first hard term can be dropped if
you do that if you they say a process of
the exposure
this one will be 16 eu0 Master Yi / u 0
square
exponential to k2t k2 is what we have in
this profit and that's the we vector in
the second a medium okay so we give the
order magnitude of this before but let's
do it again we say that for a pure waves
right the tunnelling happen when the
sickness is comparable to wavelets
so if I do thermal radiation my wavelets
occur around 10 micron and that sickness
is 10 micron or energy you start have
autonomy but for the electron wave this
K 2 is 2 m u0 must ye h bar square its
magnitude so if we go to estimate again
so here the electron mass 9.1 tenth of
the month 31 so if this you zero mass is
about the one electron volts order
magnitude right is a one point six 10 to
the minus 19 and H bar is a 1 10 to the
minus 34 so it's square 68 so this one I
will get six and 10 to the lines
universe on strong no universe meter
so you can say essentially when K times
D u when D is of the order of one
strengthen demise ten Mike's Bollinger
is a pretty appreciable right so in the
case of electron tunneling that happens
in the unstrung range in the case of all
photon tunneling happens of the order of
say wavelengths after we say thermal
wavelength right black body radiation
peak at 300 is about 10 microns so it's
a very different skill but the physics
is all similar so there are really lot
of interesting ideas using those
phenomena I told you before this finish
when he interviewed by the IBM right so
was the Oscar to think about the idea to
measure roughness of surface down to an
strong right so he did this using this
idea so this is a layer 1 a pro layer 2
is a vacuum layer 3 is the surface is
going to measure right and you apply a
bias voltage and you scan order surface
you measure current you use your current
at the feedback that's a colony right so
if your current c by based on the
current
your feedback you can maintain your
height not crash your teeth so of course
to say they did the experiment and
worked but sin they actually didn't know
where the tongue it happened because
this is the atomic skill right if you
look at the pro but they will call the
metal and cut a sharp tip or you know or
a chit so there are a lot of paper word
is tall and really happen and you you
magnify the probe you've ensured that
there is one atom in the front and
that's probably where the car goes
through
right and so finish you got a lower
price for this and but they say not of
you use the atomic force microscope
right that's also his invention he did
his he was that this was what he did at
the IBM Zurich and he wouldn't do a
Stanford for sabbatical and but he was
everybody was asking how to measure
insta laters right this was a limit to
the conductors so I read everyone how
his article he said one day I was a sick
he was lighting his apartment and look
on the roof and came up with this idea
of atomic force microscope why because
there is always a fundamentally you see
if the thinking is okay you have a solid
and you have continuo
right and your first question you say is
the I'm going to scratch the surface or
not right if you use a continual on the
surface you're worried about the data
you scratch your surface how you're
gonna measure a Tomica roughness but he
no sure this is a word a basic knowledge
this spring constant right so you know
the vibration you know the spring
constant between atoms and you go to see
you go to look at that what's a spring
constant of Canton uber what's the
spring constant between atoms and the
atoms spring on is much stiffer that
means that the cantina moreover Bend
right the stiff one moves less so people
think of this idea that's because we
have the knowledge you have to apply
your knowledge and think about this this
is an SI possible right so he has this
and of course there's the flashing so he
knows how to measure D flashing because
he put a scanning tunneling microscope
here that kind of yourself is a
conductor so if you look at how the AFM
at the beginning it was the AFM atomic
what kind anywhere plus a scanning
tunneling tip to measure this D flashing
of the kind anywhere
it was later on people say okay this is
a there's a much easier way to do it and
that's by optical D flashing because
operative flashing is magnifying the
small change in the height into angle
angle times this distance is a magnifier
because that small angular if you
magnify the distance you put a position
detector and you measure this voltage
change at different positions so that
became much easier to implement you see
that's the C you've gotta have your
knowledge and got to be creative
sometimes you also have to have a break
right okay that's the electron colony
right and the photon tunneling and you
can usually think of the same so there
are people developed are they different
for way of a full count on the
microscope one way is this is a praise
you launch the light perpendicular to
the surface so there's no total internal
reflection but at this surface there is
a total internal reflection so here
you're reflecting light your wave has an
evil action wave here and okay now
you'll bring a third surface that's a
vacuum is a layer two you'll bring you a
third layer which is a probe you brought
the clothes that were interacted with
this evil action wave and the scattered
a mean to propagate anyway so this
that's the ways people do in fact I
think a professor theater show in the
department and he would do this to try
the image say nanoparticle or a
biological object with on there I say
try to be the optical resolution the
wavelength limit right there are
different ways to do it but sometimes is
there are also creative crazy ways to
think let me give you idea that didn't
work I don't think it worked and there
was a big project by DARPA trying to do
the taller lean energy conversion
and so basically you heat up a surface
there's a tea hot this is a cheek hold
right and they want to bring the two
surfaces really close so the electron
from the hot side tunnel to the cold
side and you have power generation right
there's a company you can you can search
your web there is call the cool chips is
still there and they want to do cooling
also you you apply current and you go
tunneling electron from one side to the
other principal wise is all fine but
doing a thermal system with the answer
on to field on strong level separation
you screw the most of time right the
contact calcium right and in fact I say
there is also even last week I was the
workshop with some people were
mentioning our work because they want to
do this was a Stanford group you want to
do the tunneling the the thermionic
emission right sir Myrna Commission is
amateur has a work function and right
and a few electron volts so you if you
heat up with electrons heat up the
object the electron will evaporate
physically out of the surface right
that's a thermionic emission right so
the the problem is that when you have a
to surface close by and say not close by
far apart that when you like Tron go out
decree the potential because a charge in
the vacuum has a potential the other
electron now will see that potential
it's hard to get to the other side so
that's a space charge in fact and this
guy saw their theory and this is
Stanford group was also doing they say
okay we're doing maps fabrication to
make it smaller so the reduced space
charge defect which is fine but then
when people say okay why don't you do
this so they say all gongchan has
studied because when you're getting
really close what happens is the
tunneling alpha light actually increase
the heat transfer which you don't want
the energy conversion right so when you
don't want to gather the key
tico to close below micro that radiation
colonists are to come in and you
increase your heat transfer because this
vacuum is good but say once so you have
to see where is your balance point and
of course so we do a lot of in the
experiment and we do a lot of
experiments where this is a jihad this
is the cheek hole and we what we were
studying the radiation heat transfer
that's when the two server gets really
close I can have a colony and that were
significant say the blackbody radiation
okay
and so this are different there are very
a lot of very funny fancy interesting
physical phenomena happens at the skill
and also is interesting last question is
ask you what do you can do with it right
if you enter this it's a great impact
and some of this idea don't work but
it's good to know what's the limit okay
so what do we have done if you recall
when we start chapter five this is a
church address when the most time so far
right and what do we say what do we want
to find out is the transport between two
points point one and point two and if I
now the transmission power from one to
two and then now transmission from two
to one
right and then I know how many how much
how fast I can count to see what's the
energy flux what the momentum flux was
charged flux right you can do those type
of will transport calculations and what
we have done in the past few lectures is
see how we calculate that transmission
from one point to the other be the
interface didn't many layers right so
now we can use this lot
put the story together and write down
the transport formula if you recall so
far we have been doing the best in terms
of the energy for example is the heat
capacity the energy stored per unit
volume which is the density of states
times de l'ombre alpha say part of your
average number of particle per States
times the energy per state right so
that's they integrate together get the
total energy per unit volume but now
we're looking the flux and and from one
point to the other so let's look at this
and the this is the landau for my name's
Nanda formally formalism is actually
view of transport this relatively new is
much later than order like a Boltzmann
and say linear response Theory transport
this was developed in the 60s and 70s by
nan da hai the IBM and so the basic idea
is what we say I if I know the
transmission from 1 to 2 I can count the
flux right so let's say I want to count
heat because there are different ways
you can write for different transport
process so from point 1 to point 2 if I
allow the transmission from point 1 to
point 2 right and I can write promote
the energy let's say if that quantum
state energy and by point why I use
software the e1 right and the tau 1 2 2
they say if I have a way where the
energy e1 comes to 0.1 how much is
reaching point 2 right
if that quantum state how many number of
Parker's I have so I have a 1 and TE 1 I
use a t temperature but I put a sub
square Yi because there are some subtle
points I'm going to comment ok so this
is just a one quantum state I have not
said what's the speed right it has to
have the velocity because I'm considered
a flux so let's say if this is the Z
Direction ok so this is a t z v z1 so
you can this is a per second now energy
of a quantum state transmission from 1
to 2 how many partner in that quantum
state right now I just need to count how
many total quantum states I have that's
what you had before I sum up all the K
x1 k y1 z1 and the polarization and
that's where you stop right if you can
do this this is a for energy of course
you can do it a for momentum you can do
it for charge you can do it for entropy
you can do all transport problem ok so
my starting point and now you know once
you start writing this summation the
best way is a converting into
integration right so I can convert a say
the way of conversion the difference I
want that I do want to comment on
difference here before when we do the
heat capacity which is energy times F
sum up with the kxkykz right somehow
quantum states but here this one can
depend on the ration look when we talk
about single interface the
the angular dependent right so I don't
have the angular symmetry anymore
the velocity could also be angular
dependent so I'm losing this symmetry
and it have to be careful when I
converter using things upstairs and so
I'm going to write it out and let's say
polarization and of course K is a KX
quantum states a two PI over L X that's
the spacing right so I can always
convert an integration and DK X 2 pi LX
and in fact if I do flux I should do per
unit volume and then that will normalize
out of this of LX ly and this is a DK y
2 pi ly d kz 2 pi L Z so this is
converting the summation points into
integration points I have V Z 1 tau 1 to
2 F and E 1 t 1 ok and here you can do
so depends on KX KY KZ and typically
this F is a function of energy right so
you have the choice convert everything
in K integration or energy integration
you make your choice you have the
freedom right and I'm going to convert
into e doesn't means always convenient
the using e ok and so I have e KX d KY
decays a this is a Cartesian coordinate
right in k space not a real space k
space Cartesian coordinate and I do the
spherical coordinate in k space so d KX
d KY d kz if it's do
d KX d KY d kz is if a spherical
coordinate is K square that's the radius
sine theta D theta D Phi
that's my conversion from Cartesian to
spherical coordinate right so when you
do for example if you translate this
into a problem or interface your wave
comes in right that's your K and it has
a certain direction theta phi you can
choose your seat of Phi coordinate
yourself as long as you count that
correctly right so this is a what we're
doing in mass wise and if I do this
before again if you think about what we
had for specific heat
we had a spherical symmetry so I can
integrate the theta and Phi but my
problem is here its dependency the Phi
tau right I lose my symmetry angle
symmetry so I cannot integrate out the
general expression I lost the advantage
I had my two specific heat and in when
we do specifically we people like to do
energy integration that's why I say here
it may not be necessarily you do energy
integration is easiest you might be
doing momentum just do kxkykz
it's fine but I'm used to so what I if
you recall what we had before right we
say ok when I do this summation over say
the polarization whatever function I'm
going to do this is a F let's say that's
the one that I'm interested and I get a
4 PI K squared
okay that's when I had a spherical
symmetry right when I integrate over see
them fight and when I did that I I
converted into this is DK is DK de and
times de so all this together plus this
together gives me density of states D if
you recall right so if I combine these
things up States I got a 4 PI K square
DK k squared oh here I should have DK k
square DK is a tensile state over 4pi
okay so what I can write then kill one
to two eCourse I convert everything into
energy integration and Phi integration
is 0 2 pi if I so if you look at this
right this is my theta my as a means of
plan is a 2 pi 0 to PI and my theta
integration has to be careful because
what comes in is a it's a lot longer
it's only 0 to 90 degree it's not a zero
to 180 degree when integrated energy no
core energy is zero to 180 degree but
I'm looking at the only only cunning
welcome towards the surface so 0 90
degree so 0 PI over 2 okay DC huh and
say DK I become a de and what's left in
the bracket is raised a 1 tau 1 to 2 and
the f e 1t e 1
and times the density of states and the
e1 right so this is a de one and this is
the energy spectrum of at the point one
okay so those are the lesser evil you
have to do when you deal with transport
is to the integration in phase space see
the Phi okay or Yi depends on your
choice
oh here I'm sorry okay because there are
the four pi you recall because here when
I come where this is a 4 PI I have to do
by K squared DK have to divide 4 pi okay
and one further comment if you to expert
on this that this up state in fact that
you can write is an angle dependent if
you have an isotropic crystal in each
direction you may have different density
of states per units on the angle okay
so this is a 1 to 2 if you can write 1
to 2 you can write 2 to 1 okay Q 2 to 1
the same I'm not going to repeat use you
change all this stuff here I'm gonna
write here
okay way is a tool how to to 1f e 2t e 2
and D and I say this is a de 2 4 5 okay
everything all the integration is the
same and you have the lead difference q1
to to let difference the left flux is a
q1 to to my secure to to what
mathematically physically is very
conceptually it's very easy right it's
just the difference between the two
points
okay now comes to this a very important
point
you see if I write down this match this
there's a pretty complex that each time
I list that you have to do two times
integration - let's say integration
right and you may easily make mistakes
and that mistake is you may violate
second law when you do so so you have to
know when you do this you have to meet
the second law requirement the second
law what else you will tell you if you
have both sides at the same temperature
or you have the system either Eukanuba
right what happens it's left to right
equals right to left as simple as that
but it's very powerful and if you I
actually say some papers that do those
kind of integration at the end it is
wrong because they violate second cities
this idea and this idea is the second
law but is called the detailed balance
so principle of detail balance so what
it says are the equilibrium
and a q12 should be zero there's no let
flux and what goes from left euchre goes
from right to left it doesn't mean there
is low transport it's just a dynamic
equilibrium left the compasses right
right and with that when I rewrite the
difference
I actually from two to one you say two
to one
two point is either T 2 e 2 I can write
this Q 2 to 1 at a different temperature
equal should equal to 1 to 2 at the same
temperature T 2 so I will write this
ok so kill 2 to 1 this is at T 2 e 2 and
this should be equal to according to
detailed balance this u equal to Q 1 to
2 at T 1 T 2 and E 1 right basically if
I just look at this terminal itself a
temperature T 2 from 2 to 1 should be
equal to 1 to 2 when the one side is
also at the same temperature that's a
detail balance and the beauty of that is
now if I write the 2 to 1
everything is the integration limit
every sensor in terms of a Yi 1 right
follow me let me write down the final
expression then if I use this detail
balance I can write what I have will Q 1
2 now the leg is a Yi one you see
whether you choose one or two actually
depends on your preference depends on
the problem sometimes is easier to
gather transmittance from 1 to 2 then to
the 1 so this is e 1 and 0 to PI D Phi 0
to PI over 2 D theta and how way
Z 1 and tau 1 2 2 and D 1 4 PI and
what's the difference now is f t e 1 e 1
mass F T T 2 e 1 de 1 so I have
conveniently using the detailed balance
principle to write this expression in
terms of only one side either one side 1
or side to right and you can see I love
what level of violate the principle of
detail balance because the one two sides
are the same temperature this is zero
automatically satisfied and I save a lot
of trouble I don't need to do two
integration I only need to do Y
integration I don't need to calculate
two coefficients and in fact these two
coefficients must be related
based on my detail balance principle
right so this is a very subtle very
important and let's use this to
understand thermal boundary distance
right so many of you have heard some
abundant resistance and that's now we
understand that when I have a two medium
right even if they're perfect interface
even their atomic flat but if there are
two different materials or even same
material with a different
crystallographic configuration right
what happens is by the interface I have
wake up seeing I will have reflash it
I have transmission now that you can
calculate in principle you can calculate
right and so I know my cow this is the
one this side is a tool
and I can apply my expression here and
to get the heat flux is proportional to
the temperature difference of the two
sides right so in this case what I have
remember if you look at this what I'm
doing this is the photon coming towards
interface from one to medium to right so
this is the corresponding temperature of
this e1 and a cord is actually emitted
photon this is the incoming photon and
it's a highly long equinumerous at the
interface interface is always now in
Geneva transport there's no actually
hard to think and it's not that you can
even pass and this other side that I
have e to come in with flashing and
transmission so that's what happens and
based on the expression I have and that
you can say here if they temperature
difference on the two sides are not very
different I can do differentiation of
the other F so I can write this as DF DT
times t1 minus t2 right okay and the
other Chi over Q is defined as the
thermal resistance so if I have a
boundary I have reflection I will get
resistance and it's same for an immature
if you have a charged reflashing you get
the electrical resistance you know is a
phonon reflashing got thermal resistance
so and this q1 2 equals t1 must he - and
our prime and let me actually also put
this is re prime double prime that's a
specific set of on resistance so the
unit here will be me
square Kelvin per watt for this it's a
specific per unit area so if you have
another area you divided by that okay
so what
so here based on this you can say I can
calculate the thermal boundary
resistance II and zero to PI D Phi zero
PI over two and the theta way z1 and how
1 to 2 and E 1 DF DT and tens'up States
D 1 4 PI and D e1 so in theory now you
can calculate this term you calculate in
some states you know this you know the
band structure you know this this
velocity out discussed next ok so you
can calculate everything right and but
you should ask me a problem I'm waiting
for the question to be asked you see
there's some problem here that is if my
transmissivity equals 1 what happens
for my transmissivity course one is this
a zero resistance is not zero right so
what's the problem
in fact that the first paper on this was
written by Ledo it's time for a proposal
was this I think it was Snell full
professor and he had a discussion of
this let's say you say this is what
happens if you have an imaginary surface
right I say this is not applicable you
have to do this
our mean free path so but they to the
problem really lies in how we define
temperature this is a highly lung
equilibrium process at the interface
right and temperature is defined based
on moral equilibrium concept and if we
think about either equilibrium the
distribution function is isotropic right
there's no the ration and what happens
at this interface if you look at it I
say this is the incoming this is the
other side incoming each side you have a
different spectrum right you know that
is this together
give me the spectrum different energy
distribution right so what I really say
what's really the temperature at this
point the temperature at that point if
you think about the local energy density
at a point gives you the temperature if
you go back to the specific heat
calculation right the local energy is
related to the local temperature and
that local energy is defined based on
all the Russians and when I look at this
point my energy on the left side let's
say this is my t1 this is my t - I say
it's different than t1 t2 that's because
when I look at a point 1 right I have
those photons coming
that's a house the crystalline te one
that's the only hundred eighty degree on
this side right that's incoming the
other is outgoing that's so they are 180
unless I look at this this is incoming
that's this side the outgoing on this
side is a reflection of the surface
itself so reflection depends on
reflectance and the angular dependence
it may not be symmetric at all that's
one part the other part is in my
transmission here on this side once it
transmitted that's again modulated by my
transmission which has an angular
dependence so this is a transmission so
I add this two together that gives me
the go into either the ration that
depart and then it may not completely
unsymmetric and the local energy should
be defined based on you add this part at
this part at this part and divide by if
it's the equivalent temperature right so
if you do a equivalent temperature t1
and t2 you do your redo energy balance
you will be different because this t1
well clearly depends on not only in the
end temperature comes in but also the
transmitter from the other side right so
you will have to write the relation at
the end your expression that's in the
book I'm not going to rewrite it you get
a different thermal minor resistance and
that was in the matter when transmission
to one is to zero okay I wrote that and
that people typically do not so I can
put help my own group or you need to
read my chapter five because they don't
they don't you have to really carefully
to understand that because very often
people are comparing wrong sense the
dual experiment and they will compare
with this theory
but the water they really measure is
this tool and you compare an apple and
orange and you'll see sometimes they
have perfect comparison you know
something is wrong
okay but this is not just this one
problem it's actually you you want to
check a literature it's everywhere
people discuss it people really do this
kind of research leave noise let me give
examples and so if you now you can use
this to understand there are many
interesting phenomena what we discuss
here is the thermal boundary resistant
that's where I'm really interested so I
spend time on but say in electron so if
you have a wire or attack right people
do a lot of this kind of experiment
where they measure the voltage here V 1
and V 2 and go through a wire and when
the wire is very small you go to very
low temperature you got a quantized
conductance and that conductance is
actually independent of material it's a
universal and same if you do heat at the
very low temperature this is all in the
book the example problem you get a
universal heat conductance is the
independent Mathieu okay and then the
question is there was a question that's
often people ask if it's publicity why
you have resistance at all ballistic
means to go from one point to the other
why you have resistant air all right you
see here is those are the ballistic
conduct quantized conductance right and
the this really depends on the the
definition and in the case of under your
experiment in the case where people do
this quantized conductance measurement
for example you have a carbon nanotube
you measure the conductance you put a
two metal electrodes right and so you
have a nanotube
you put a two metal electrodes and what
do you measure is not this temperature
or electrochemical potential you
measuring the drain and the source this
is the average over a large area so
whether what does that mean is what
launching into this region correspond to
what you measure that's a what's
launched is your immediate electron is
if you have a chance if you there is a
way to measure exactly the potential
here for income in + policy going from
this side to the other side right then
this point at this point there is a
simple tension if you use that simple
treasurer you get an infinite
conductance okay so it's really how you
because those are all a long
equinumerous s and depends on how you do
your measurement how you do your say and
you interpret it so in electrical
engineering I remember I was reading a
book there was a whole section devoted
to this discussion and in fact there you
go to check I once I was in look into
this paper
professor particularly in physics
department had a few papers on this
quantized conductance the same problem
same felt I say different fields is just
a really you you have to spend your time
to understand it finally just as another
example for you to think is that when I
have two black body radiation returned
to surface right in vacuum t1 t2 what's
the temperature of photon inside there's
no equilibria you have to
counter-propagating photon they don't
interact now if you have this black body
absorber
neither disc and one side a absorb t1 on
the other side of you absorb t2 so at
the end of your absorber temperature
will be T force equals t1 force plus t2
force average and that temperature
is a union form here right but when you
stick a thermocouple you measure this
hot side you measure another photon
temperature you imagine a solid
temperature you stick a stomach on this
side you measure in the solid
temperature so when you do your ply body
you see my Q equals Sigma T one-fourth
power minus t2 horsepower right and it's
correspondingly you do your Q over Delta
T that's your conductance right it's not
infinite however if you are able to put
this detector and measure this point at
this point is the same temperature you
should get a conductance the infinite
right so it depends on how you define
you have to be careful that's my point
okay I'll stop here